life is like a bunch of Korean snacks
you never know what they're eating till
you open it it feels like Harry Potter
having burped about beans for the first
time it's like this the first time I
were like oh yeah
masala shadnagar sada Gordon food for me
would be anything that has films or
anything under the ocean if it says for
any I'm on the packet it has to be fun
and young right very bland
there's no masala there's no taste it
tastes a little bit like nothing really
I don't generally like people do this
pretty creative it's like just having
fried flour this is peanut born and this
is peanut bored spicy so the only women
know that because it says right here in
English I will sweep on the inside so I
don't know why I call it spicy perfect
Chuck now food in India you get a peanut
snack then the spicy snack separately
this is like you know yes like mash into
the fusion dance and lashes together and
then you get Korean food so amongst the
two I think that I can keep on having
for a long but you know channel just
like one of those chocolates when you
eat them you think it's really good but
after two bites you're owning it now we
have crunchy rice rolls here which look
a bit like Rice Krispies cereal bars is
exactly like Rice Krispies again
tasteless it just has a little hint of
sweetness in it in it and that's it I
didn't tell really love it or I didn't
hate it it's fine I could eat it very
mild and very light and tips it's a good
sweet way to end a meal I would like to
draw your attention to the back where a
can show sample choco biscuit winks very
suggestively at the user near the top
they know what they're doing they can't
overload it with sugary stuff like
Indian and American snacks so it's
chocolate inside a biscuit and then you
bite into it and stuff it pulls it out
don't none of that happened to me I love
I love all of it I mean oh yeah I did
love it all of these products lack
singing is electric
most of it the magic formula is when in
doubt add 200 grams of red chili powder
which which I think should should be
followed